depuis des années c'est la mode à la
télévision de relance et d'anciens
formats qui ont marqué une génération
c'est le cas par exemple de la famille
en or à prendre ou à laisser
ou encore il ya quelques années star
academy sur nrj 12 les rebelles veulent
souvent payant c'est sans doute la
raison pour laquelle tf1 réfléchir et
aujourd'hui retour d'un programme qui a
marqué la télé réalité secretstory
si l'émission avait pris fin en 2017 à
l'occasion de la onzième saison du
programme animé alors par christophe
beaugrand
de nombreuses rumeurs circulent sur le
come back de la maison des secrets ici
la fois mais c'est le blogueur aquabaie
qui a relancé les suspicions autour d'un
possible retour du jeu sur snapshot le
jeune homme a posté une photo de la
maison des secrets qui seraient
actuellement en cours de nettoyage par
des équipes de professionnels une maison
pourtant laissé à l'abandon depuis la
fin du jeu il ya trois ans en plus de
cet indice un autre internaute a signalé
qu'il aurait aperçu à plusieurs reprises
de la lumière provenant de cette maison
perchée sur un immeuble aubervilliers
près de paris a encore voilà des années
qu'il n'y avait eu aucune activité
un faisceau d'indicés qui relance un peu
plus fort les rumeurs alors cycle astori
bientôt de retour à la télé alors oui
alors c'est vraiment celle des petits
indices à la maison des travailleurs qui
hélas je n'ai pas entendu du tout à
notre sens aimé vous dire ce jeu c'est
bien conseil de n'était pas vu ce qu'on
vit en ce moment avec les gens sont
confinés voilà une émission les gens
sont renfermés
on pourra ressortir ses serres
d'actualité mais à mon avis ça forge et
aux gourmets remercie tout le monde à
part que le big brother le format existe
encore version célébrités au canada ces
vins est relancé la marque n'est pas
morte mais c'est vrai que le retour
d'anciens formats et très phénomène en
mai là où vous inciter à prendre ou à
laisser ou encore la famille en or ce
sont des jeux un jeu c'est beaucoup
moins cher à vocation de fédérer les
jeux c'est pas la même mécanique qu'une
téléréalité est aujourd'hui les
téléréalités franchement et tout ce qui
se fait ailleurs w9
s'il resterait aujourd'hui le problème
avec moi c'est que sur la fin on était
vraiment ringard par rapport aux autres
nous nous faisait un défilé dans la
maison et où il était et une salade
financées c'est beaucoup plus cher cent
mille euros en moyenne la quotidienne
alors qui est un talk show s'est
largement le rend si certains jouent
c'était sur les lots il y avait une
grosse marge mais surtout je me suis
renseigné un peu sur les audiences vous
quand vous étiez en saison 8 sur tf1
faisait entre deux millions 5 et 3
millions de spectateurs en utiliser
partie de soirée de préciser pourquoi
m'avez-vous période
et quand christophe beaugrand
je n'accuse pas christophe beaugrand
mais quand il a récupéré la marque sur
tf6 il faisait quatre cent mille c'est
une marque qui est morte elle était
ringard 10 et comblé dit par les
marseillais et les anges de la télé
réalité
voilà tout c'est toutes ces célébrités
donc pour moi voilà j'y crois pas trop à
ce combat mais qu'il se fasse et de tf1
tat est fixé un peu comme si vous
divorcez d'horreur pour mépriser que ce
serait quand même excellent vannes